- Do you like that sound? (chuckling)
(whooshing)
(squeaking)
(light music)
- Uh, what am I eating again?
I forgot.
- I'm here to eat some sort
of international food snack.
- [Man] What if I told you that's not
what you're here to do?
- I figured that was the case.
- You're gonna ask me
to do some weird shit.
I don't want to eat an insect.
- I hope it's something
that's not gonna try
to harm me violently.
- I don't think we're allowed
to eat poop on camera, right?
(upbeat music)
I'm gonna cry, baby.
- [Man] Now you've got to mash them up
and turn them into one thing.
- That's exactly what
I already wanted to do.
- This is gonna completely ruin this
for the rest of my life.
- This is so mean.
- This is maybe the most
exciting day of my life.
- Double quarter pounder with cheese
which is what I was gonna get
for lunch in like 15 minutes
and a crunch wrap supreme.
- Alright, this is a breakfast burrito
from Jack in the Box.
This is a two piece from Popeye's.
- This is a mexi-melt,
sausage McMuffin with egg.
- Taco Bell classic taco,
In-N-Out cheeseburger,
animal style, protein style.
You just want me to do it on this table?
It's gonna be so gross.
- This is just wonderful.
- How do you want to
fit together, friends?
- Feel like what I need
to do is empty it out
into the sandwich.
- [Man] Do you think it's gonna be good?
- Yeah.
- I feel like we can
just put this crunch wrap
in the middle of this cheeseburger.
- I could just put the taco in the burger.
- And then do a little wrap around.
- This is actually kind of beautiful.
- I basically put a two piece and biscuit
into an already breakfast burrito.
- In-N-Out burger,
garden style with a taco
right in the middle.
- Oh my god, this is like Christmas.
- I'll take my Lactaid pills first
so I don't die.
- Uhh, it looks gross.
- Oh, it's gonna be so good.
(upbeat music)
This may be the most delicious thing
I've ever eaten in my entire life.
- Man, I don't think there's
a more distinct taste
than that ground beef from Taco Bell.
- Holy (bleep).
- The sausage overpowers a lot of stuff.
- It doesn't even taste
like Taco Bell or McDonald's anymore,
it's like a whole new thing.
- They're way better separated.
- They complement each other really well.
I'm just a little faklempt at
how excited I am about this.
I'm gonna cry.
This is really good.
- The sensory overload
would be the perfect way
to explain this burrito.
It's a little bit too many meats.
- And you can always use
the tortilla as a napkin.
- It's weird how one of my favorite things
can ruin my over favorite thing.
- This is definitely like an enjoying it
in the privacy of your own home food.
- I don't deserve this sandwich.
- Maybe if I was really drunk.
- This is all I can have now.
I can't go to one of
these restaurants anymore.
- I'm just so thankful that
I got to experience that.
It's something I always wanted to do
but I never really knew
that it was a possibility.
- I would probably never do it again.
- You learn something new everyday,
and what I've learned is
that if you mix Taco Bell
and In-N-Out, it's pretty good.
- The meat sweats are happening already.
(whooshing)
(squeaking)